in samurai legend and in samurai
terminology Aronian is a samurai without
a cause without a purpose Wolverine is
the ultimate outsider and in our movie
which takes place after x-men 3 he's
probably more isolated than you've ever
seen more for it you're not a hunter are
you not anymore
this is a character that is so sick of
living and so sick of his healing power
he has lost purpose and it's a dangerous
place for someone as powerful as
Wolverine that hurt
[Music]
the beginning of our story takes place
in World War two
it's Nagasaki bombs about to drop
there's panic everywhere that's where
Hogan meets a young Yashida huh nope he
ends up saving his life
some sixty years later the young yashide
has grown into being probably the most
powerful businessman in Japan I've been
trying to find you for over a year
my employer wants to say thank you for
saving his life all those years ago
oh you look the same but then there's no
surprise it's good to see you again he
sees in Wolverine someone who has the
ability to live who doesn't necessarily
want it I can end your eternity make him
water what they did to me what I am
can't be undone don't be so sure
[Music]
Wolverine without his healing power it's
another story his flesh is weak now what
are you hiding what did you grandfather
tell you when they read his will you are
not the man to lead yash them all we
become the most powerful person in Japan
that armor belonged to the silver
samurai it will stand watch over the old
man forever
he's never quite sure who he can trust
somebody's done right battle plays out
on these different levels in the face of
both ancient and modern Japan between
ninjas and Viper and silver samurai you
seek over more volume you're going to
die Logan maybe that's okay more at risk
and more of a monster than you've ever
seen it before so you've come to fight
it's pointless we are number
is that all the men you brought
kind of Mostar are you the Wolverine
you
you